una bomba atómica para la economía de
hungría así escribió el primer ministro
húngaro viktor orbán la prohibición a la
importación del petróleo ruso propuesta
por la unión europea como parte de las
sanciones a moscú
no hay compromiso en este momento en
absoluto entonces no hay acuerdo acabo
de recibir el texto y no hay acuerdo por
supuesto esto force hungría obtiene el
85 por ciento de su gas natural y más
del 60 por ciento de su petróleo
procedente de rusia
orbán afirma que su país necesitaría al
menos cinco años y una gran inversión en
refinerías y oleoductos para poder
transformar su sistema actual para el
gobierno húngaro la inversión requerida
para la transformación de la
infraestructura estaría por el orden de
los 15 a los 18 mil millones de euros
sólo podemos apoyar este cambio si no
causa costos impagable para hungría y
las familias húngaras y hoy lo haría por
lo tanto necesitamos fondos para el
cambio y un periodo de transición en la
condición del apoyo
hungría también se niega a apoyar la
inclusión en la lista de sanciones del
líder de la iglesia ortodoxa rusa al
kremlin bajo el argumento de libertad
religiosa en cuanto a las armas la
posición de hungría es no enviarlas a
ucrania porque los envíos podrían
convertirse en objetivos de ataques
rusos en la frontera occidental de
ucrania donde viven personas de etnia
húngara